Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, we are looking at trauma stabilisation. What is it? Why does it matter?
And what sort of results can it achieve for the clients who go through it? What sort of results can it achieve for the clinicians delivering it? We're looking at getting research published and making a difference at the right time for the client. I hope you find this so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I feel like there's not much of an intro to make for today's episode actually because I think we did a really wonderful job of handling it as kind of almost a standalone
episode. I'm chatting with Amy Shipp who is a qualified clinical associate psychologist and we're talking about group programs for stabilization and I just found it a really wonderful, wonderful episode to record and yeah, I hope you find it really useful. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. Enjoy. I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Amy. Hi, Amy. Hiya. Thank you for joining us. We connected on LinkedIn, which is the start of many a podcast episode that I say, but I just, I really love the interesting things that are going on in the psychology world and it just sparks my interest for podcasts. So before we get thinking about what we're going to talk about
today, could you tell us a little bit about yourself and your kind of psychology history so far? Of course. So I am a CAP, quite a new role. I think many people are learning a lot about it now. And I first started with psychology back in secondary school and just really took a shine to it. Just found it really interesting in terms of just learning about why people did things the way that they do and how everything that we experience impacts us. And took it further from there really studied psychology at a level study psychology for my undergrad and initially I had kind of different thoughts as to where I wanted to go within that route so I took a forensic psychology master's with the intention of going down the forensic route and had a bit of a change of heart following
the clinical route and that led me to the clinical associate in psychology role and the training course which has been great. I see very nice thank you yeah forensics I all my assistant work was forensic stuff but I always knew I didn't want to be a forensic psychologist it's just that that was the experience that I'd managed to get but forensics is not for everybody you know um I wasn't really that keen to return to forensics after I qualified I felt like I'd kind of earned those stripes and was looking forward to kind of non-forensic work but um it is the real deal there's a lot to process isn't there in forensic settings yeah most definitely and I think for me it was something I realized um was an interest of mine but perhaps not where I wanted to work
clinically okay so a good experience nonetheless yeah and that's actually a really nice way of looking at it you know you can take a look but you don't necessarily need to make that your career. And that reminds me of when I was training, doing my doctorate, that you kind of, that's what placements are for. We're taking a look. We're trying on some different shoes here. We don't necessarily need to keep them. We can move forward and decide what kind of psychologist I want to be. And that found you working as a clinical associate psychologist. If people are interested in knowing more about the role and the training of clinical associate psychologists, we've had a very recent episode with Dr. Dawn Reeves, who is working in Essex Partnership University Trust, looking at that
role for adults. But we also had an episode a little bit earlier on with Elise Dyer looking at the training role for children and young people caps so if that's okay I mean we won't cover that too much because we've covered that a little bit already but I am really really interested to think about your work in adult mental health and to think about how that's landed you with a publication and how you're hopefully setting the world of trauma-informed care and service delivery alight do you want to pick up that that baton run with that for a bit yeah it's been um it's been really interesting. I worked as an assistant psychologist in my current service
before doing the CAP training and the service itself kind of came to light in the midst of the first pandemic lockdown and we recognised, and this is probably something that a lot of people recognize across the country and not just in the area that I'm in um this real kind of gap between primary and secondary care with lots of um lots of people falling through that gap and not the kind of service remit existing that can provide the things that those people need. And oftentimes that tends to be for people who are experiencing the after effects of complex trauma. So we had a real task in setting up the service, which was designed to essentially fill that gap between primary and secondary care. It's kind of a transformational project that looked at reducing that siloed working that was existing between primary and secondary and also third sector organisations
to help us work together more collaboratively. So we designed this service that now exists with the idea of capturing those people that fall in between. And we take a lot of learning from the neuro sequential model by Bruce Perry and the phased approach to trauma therapy that's kind of been advised by Herman. And it's, you know, in a lot of our guidelines that exist now for managing and treating complex PTSD. So we developed this service that's essentially got layers to the service and is very formulation driven very trauma informed and as part of that that kind of layered approach we focus on that from that neuro neuro sequential perspective so the kind of lower end levels of our interventions or our support focuses on that kind of bottom-up processing and as you move higher we start to to approach those top-down processing
methods and sitting within that is an online complex trauma stabilization group that we developed which we've we've recently published some research about amazing it's so important and it's just trying to make sure that we are you know we're mopping up any gaps really and in case people are listening to this thinking hmm primary care secondary care don't quite know what that is so primary care is something like your gp that you can self-refer to there might be lower level interventions secondary care is something that you ordinarily would need a a referral to and you might get kind of higher level perhaps more intensive intervention is that
is that how you understand the the definition the separation between the two amy if i got that right yeah absolutely and i think with secondary care it tends to be um where that kind of longer term support is needed as well. Sometimes multiple professionals to be involved as well. Lovely, thank you Amy. So tell me about your research then. So for the past few years now we have been offering this complex trauma stabilization group that's run online currently. And the idea of it really is to kind of sit in that first phase of that approach to trauma therapy essentially mostly focusing on things like safety and stabilization in order to prepare people for moving forward in that pathway to potentially go on to reprocess traumatic experiences and it's something that didn't really exist in this area we have um support services available for kind of single incident ptsd um but what we noticed is there's a lot of people that were
being missed because of experiences of complex trauma so those ongoing repeated experiences of trauma that often start in childhood and And, and whilst the impact of that is in some ways similar to, to a single incident PTSD, um, presentation. So, you know, your intrusive symptoms, um, there is kind of that additional, um, layer, I suppose, um, which we refer to as disturbances and self-organization. So, you know, those things that impact, like your ability to regulate your emotions, that kind of perception of yourself and your role, as some people kind of see that. And also just those difficulties in terms of interacting with others and those kind of see that and also just those difficulties in terms of interacting with others and those
kind of interpersonal relationships so a lot of those people are being missed so what we're doing with this group is essentially enabling those people to be able to receive the support that they need in terms of reprocessing those traumas and being able to live a better quality of life starting off with the the trauma group um and it it's a it's a 12-week group that we run um in an online format two hours weekly that of course this break there's breaks in that as well um but we we essentially move through the group um to provide a better understanding of why people experience these particular difficulties following complex trauma and how that kind of fits in in terms of the way in which our brains work generally as human beings and how that's altered through the experience of trauma and then providing people with strategies to essentially
almost stabilize symptoms so to better regulate emotions to develop more compassionate ways of relating to themselves and to the difficulties that they experience um and predominantly the the group itself is based on principles of cbt um but we also draw upon things like um dialectical behavior therapy so dbt compassion focused therapy um in order to provide that psychoeducation about trauma and those strategies. We've run many groups now. I think we're on about group number 21, which we first started this particular therapy group around three to four years ago now. And yeah, just being a pilot service, being a pilot group as well, it's really important to us to make sure it's doing what we want it to do and actually having a positive impact for people.
But also exploring, you know, like the service user experience of that as well, because we have this knowledge and these ideas that we want to share with people to support them but obviously the experience of receiving that needs to be helpful and compassionate and containing as well so that's what we looked to do in this particular piece of research we we did a service evaluation of this particular group um to look at the the outcomes um any kind of clinical change um but also exploring people's experience of that group as well lovely so important to measure what we're doing isn't it and you know we're doing that by doing outcome measures at the start at the midpoint at the end point um some services are asking you to do after every session as well but some of them feel like overkill um i this really resonated with me because when i was working in the in the nhs i realized that i was for every new patient i was picking up
doing complex trauma work i was doing the same stuff you know the same stabilization program and I just thought this would be totally doable in a group um and so I put together a stabilization group and for me um I knew that a lot of the clients that I was working with would have found it really difficult being with another gender so we we made it male or female now and you know we now operate in a slightly different context and so how I would do that now I think we'd have to take some additional thoughts and consideration but if it was their cameras were on or the gallery wasn't on maybe it wouldn't really matter I don't
know something to consider I'll ask you about your experience with that in a minute as well but we then so I started this group and it worked really well um and then um the pandemic came along and so then we were doing some bits online as well um actually also in my own business I then I did a pre-record course which I was calling the feel better academy which guides people through all of this stuff because um you know whilst connection is important it still takes you know person hours doesn't it to deliver it and some people want to just be able to get the skills but not actually necessarily aren't ready for the connection as yet. So how have you navigated the kind of gender, you know, because often the complex trauma
presentation is, well, it's from childhood and it might be that it's arisen because of specific genders. So then this is for our audience being vulnerable and around people of that gender can feel really triggering for people, understandably. How have you navigated that, Amy? So our groups are mixed gender, but prior to anyone kind of accessing that particular group, they will have a formulation or some kind of assessment where those kinds of things would be discussed and often you know it's kind of a mixed bag really actually in terms of whether people feel comfortable with a group program or not and sometimes there is that
uncertainty because often complex trauma stems from relations with other people. And with that relational trauma, there's going to be anxiety around interacting in groups. There's going to be that fear of being triggered. So we have a mixed gender group. But alongside those 12 group sessions, we provide three individual sessions that group members have prior to starting the group midway through and at the end and during those one-to-one sessions there's the opportunity to discuss any anxieties or concerns and to also problem solve and think about how best to support individuals much of that is talking about, I guess, the kind of expectations for the group in terms of what they can expect from the group. So there's, you know, there's no
expectation or pressure for anyone to talk about their traumatic experiences where they're purely for that first stabilization part. So to take those strategies and to learn more and we have a conversation about how to keep safe during the group and outside of the group sessions what will we do if someone feels triggered how will we manage that as a group and there's a real emphasis in the group particularly in the first couple of sessions about safety and connectedness so how we can ensure that all of our group members feel safe in that space and feel comfortable and also how we stay connected because we know that dissociation is a really common survival strategy and when triggered in the group likelihood is that dissociation will become activated um and then how do people cope
and reconnect safely um that being said we do also offer this particular group program as a brief psychological intervention on a one-to-one um so if at the point of formulation, there were real strong aversions to working with or being exposed to a person of another gender, we can consider actually, is it more appropriate and more useful to this person to offer them this support on a one to one basis? So that's that's kind of how we've been tackling it thus far. We do, when we're talking to people about joining this particular group therapy, talk to them about the pros of group therapy as well, because although a daunting experience, and often people do feel anxious about that, there are lots of pros. Again, thinking about that nature of complex trauma and that relational trauma. Of course, being around other people, that threat system is going to become activated.
And we talk to people about, you know, with this being a therapy group, there's multiple therapists there to help contain that group space. Being surrounded by people with similar experiences who are also working towards similar goals can be really encouraging and really invalidating. And so also, you know, a group therapy being an opportunity to safely sort of tackle those beliefs and anxieties about other people um but again it's it's a real important um ethos in our service to consider right thing right order right time so if a group therapy is not the right thing right now for someone it may be that we offer them this program on a one-to-one instead um and support them moving forward oh it sounds like such a responsive compassionate service to work in um well that just sounds really nice sounds
really nice and i hope that you're getting wonderful subjective feedback as well as objective feedback because sometimes that's the stuff that really helps as a clinician isn't it when you're getting actually when this was done and when you did this it really made me feel this and this is how this has made a difference in my life it's those golden moments isn't it that just I think stay with you probably for the rest of your career that you can really reflect on most definitely um and whilst there isn't that expectation to talk about um traumatic experiences people do in the group talk about you know for example this happened to me last week and i felt really triggered and we'll relate that to what we've learned in the group um you know how that makes sense based upon what we know about the way brains work and
and the way brains and memories work during traumatic experiences and I think often people find that to be really helpful that validation um of their experience and their difficulties and and linking that in with what we're learning in the group. And I think having that space to connect with others is something people have found really valuable and shared with us too. And even some of the concepts, we talk quite a lot about the window of tolerance. So that way of helping to gauge your emotions
and your levels of arousals based upon kind of different things that happen and and how we can cope with that and I think that's been a real learning point for people and a really helpful experience so there's always opportunity within the group sessions to share that experience and to share how you're finding the group and And again, in those one-to-one sessions, we always provide that opportunity to reflect upon what is helpful in the group, what's been unhelpful or challenging, how do we problem solve that,
how do we help you? But also recognizing that with that therapist to service user relationship, for some, it might not always be easy to highlight or bring up or speak about things that have been difficult or things that haven't been the most positive experience so we also do give all of our group members um like a feedback form um like link that they can complete um and they can just say what they want to about that group experience and it's
all anonymous so we'll not know who it that group experience and it's all anonymous so we'll not know who it's come from and that's been really really helpful as well lovely and just yeah I think it's just utter magic when your group members are hearing bits from people's lives over the week and And then one of them might say, Oh, I wonder if actually this is that thing that we were talking about the other week. And could it be this and, you know, might this have been useful? And, you know, they start to kind of really apply the theory to the practice, or someone will say, actually, in the moment, I recognize that this was this and I did this.
And it, you know, or I used to love it when people would come in and they would be, you'd see, oh, you get it. You're not using these skills. You know, they might be sharing an office with somebody and they'd be like, and I just looked at them as they were telling a story and I just realized how unregulated they were. And I just said, take a breath, drop your shoulders. And then you're like, oh, and then once you begin to be able to see how unregulated, once you begin to see what regulation looks like in you, you begin to see how unregulated other people are and once you begin to see that you can then begin to shape the world and you are a more compassionate better human and you are just more stable and you are you have a different impact on the world I think have you experienced any of that absolutely um I think even as a practitioner like delivering the group, you learn so much as you're supporting people, too.
And it's absolutely the case. Like once you're able to better regulate, you start to notice that dysregulation in others and how you can support them. And that's even been feedback that we've had from people completing the group. One of the biggest things that some people have taken away with them is that self-awareness and that ability to recognize where they them not only in helping to regulate themselves but some of our group members have have spoken to me about how that's then helped them to recognize that dysregulation in their children or in other people around them and then support them to notice what's going on to take that step back like you say that breath drop the shoulders um so it's been a really a really positive experience yeah I love it and sometimes my kids especially my youngest will say to me mummy it's all right let's come and have a cuddle have a sit down like we'll just sit on the sofa and it's oh you're gonna be okay you're gonna be okay kid like you're attuned
and you're not making me feel awful for being a little bit shoutier or you know have you had a tricky day mummy like what's going on yeah she doesn't it doesn't call me mummy publicly anymore so to save his embarrassment I will I will say in public he calls me mum behind closed doors he does still call me mummy and I love it um but yeah like the window of tolerance is just so so useful and I think about it all the time and it's the it's what I call the roadmap for all of the work that I do with my clients but another of my favorites is this idea of um I don't know if you've if you've kind of got this concept in your group, but a bicycle wheel. And like we might just kind of notice things arise on the rim and we can choose where to show, you know, to pay our attention. And then there's part of that. There's a really nice kind of guided imagery exercise where you imagine yourself sitting at the bottom of an
ocean you can breathe you know you're not you're not struggling for breath or anything it's supposed to be tranquil and you just are looking up towards the surface and you might be able to see the sort of choppy waves you might be able to see the sun coming down but you're not you're not in the thick of that and so it's that ability to kind of just slightly absent yourself to be able to think about what is whipping you up into a frenzy and whether that actually is deserving of your time and attention right now and just slowing everything down I really love that have you got a favorite kind of strategy or thing from your group that actually you just love doing or that you use for yourself that is a very good question um I think it really depends to be honest what you need in the moment
and that's something that we talk to people in the group about all of the time you know there's lots of different ways that we can help ourselves to regulate um and you'll need different things at different times based upon where you are on that bicycle wheel or where you are um you know in that window of tolerance I think for me one of my personal favorites is just using your senses to soothe you and reground you um because i think when we think about complex trauma and just generally day-to-day like life stresses that we experience that information comes in through our senses essentially and and travels up to the you know through the nervous system up to the brain and sends that particular message and i just find it really interesting how we can use that same process to reground and re-regulate ourselves and I think if you know when we think back to being a child
or when we think about children around us a lot of the time the things that they need or want for self-regulation relates to senses like children come to adults or parents around us for a hug you know that's a tactile um touch response or sense um and I find that that really interesting because I think especially when you're an adult it can sometimes be more difficult to know what do I do like when I was a kid I would want a hug but I can't always get a hug um and I think the senses are just a lovely way of bringing that in um and I often think sharing that kind of sensory understanding and that neurobiological understanding behind the skill is something that people really find um almost like a light bulb moment I think a lot of
people when when you kind of suggest it to them at first they're like well how is listening to the sounds of rain and and lighting a candle going to soothe me but when you explain that and the importance of engaging all of those senses at once it seems to click so much and it's just one that I personally find to be the most soothing for me as well thank you for running with that question that I threw at you you did a beautiful job of it I've got a candle burning right now I just yeah for me it feels like a little bit of me indulgence time and I just yeah love everything you said basically I'm such a mammal um I am five foot six and my husband is six foot two I'm gonna say and I just still love a cuddle stand-up cuddles
the best does that sound really dodgy um you know just I like I like cuddles and sometimes I'll say I think I need a hug um and if my little one's upset he still likes to scooch up like and have like a koala hug um I can sort of just about manage to hold him like that and just you know I just love it and like as a mummy I'm the sort of person that will scooch down to the floor and like shuffle him onto my knee and then just sort of sit there as we have a chat and we'll I still do that with my big one as well at bedtime I get him to sit on my knee or sit on stairs with me to hear about their day I'm just a mammal and at night time I don't mind sharing
with you all that at night time as we're watching tv my husband fusses my hair for me like I love a bit of stroking I love a bit of just a little bit of yeah I'm just a mammal you know I'd be the sort of monkey that would sit sit being groomed or grooming others in a row and even at primary school we used to do that we used to sit in a row doing each other's hair and stroking each other's backs and stuff like not everyone is into sensory stuff but actually what we know about living in groups is that you know it's supposed to feel good but for some reasons stuff that's happened in our past it can feel triggering can't it absolutely um and that again is why it's so important in the group for us to give people a range of different skills that they
use because some people will not be drawn to like self-soothing with the senses um and not only that but i guess also highlighting the importance in the group of using the skills in a way that works for you and a way that feels manageable for you um and sometimes you know it might be that there are certain parts of self-soothing with the senses for for example, that people really enjoy, but it might be the touch aspect that they don't enjoy. And knowing it's okay to not engage that sense and just roll with the ones that work for you. Similarly, some of the other skills, again, people will find them really interesting
and be really drawn to them. And for others, it will feel really triggering one of the the other skills that we go over is imagining that calm place um and for some that's really really soothing but for others that the idea of that in itself can be triggering because there is no place that they felt calm or safe before um and yeah i think that's just really important to to acknowledge and and something that we kind of preface with the the group sessions as well because there are a lot of different skills that we go over we go through distress tolerance and emotion regulation skills from dbt we go through um skills from like cft as well so things like the soothing rhythm breathing um developing that
compassionate self um and each of those will land differently with different people and that's okay it's about developing the toolkit that works for you and you know what might work really well for us where we just talked about you know that sensory aspect for some that will just feel completely overwhelming and overstimulating and not the thing that they need so yeah just about individualizing things absolutely when i used to run the group in person i used to take um a white company cassis spray with me and i'd sort of spray the room so that we're kind of starting to establish like a safe, comforting, calming scent. Unfortunately, they don't make that scent anymore.
But it was still something I used to say with online work. You can kind of spray the room like something that can be something new so that you begin to associate that with something calm, stable, secure and OK. Thank you. That's been really interesting to hear more about your programme. In terms of how you get it published, you know, does this class's audit where you don't need ethics? Do you kind of need to go through the ethical hoops? How has that worked out for you? So a colleague of mine led on this particular piece of research um actually as part of her training for the doctorate in clinical psychology um so it was something that i supported her with so she i will give all credit to her in terms of doing all of the wonderful things like setting up the research and all of our questions and organising ethical approval and whether that was needed and that kind of thing.
And my role was predominantly from delivering the group and collecting all of the the information um but this particular piece of um research as such is it kind of more comes under the remit of like audit and evaluation um so we didn't need kind of full ethical approval just talking more so to like um just to like the the internal committees within um research and development and um that kind of department in in the trust fabulous and you really nicely demonstrated how you can get involved in research so um when i was an assistant i definitely helped support trainees um and they agreed that I could kind of put that as kind of honorary research work on my on my forms and I helped with some research when I was an assistant which then got me my first publication which then allowed me to do
a presentation which counted as a dissemination so I really do think that if you're looking to progress your career in psychology that getting involved in research is so so important do you want to name check your colleague whose research this is I absolutely will my colleague is Alana Foreman and she is doing some wonderful things like this piece of research lovely is it open access can anybody kind of read the whole thing or is it just the abstract they can read? I believe it's open access. I don't currently, our trust doesn't have like access
to all publications, but I can download it and read it. So it should be available. But for those who are registered, like studying university or something, they'll be able to access it anyway. Okay, I will make sure that I pop a link to it in the show notes. So if anybody wants to be able to take a read of it, they absolutely can. Before we finish, have you got any advice for any aspiring psychologists out there to reduce burnout, Amy? in this career pathway and trying to reach certain goalposts within certain times and get experience for this for your application and go experience here and there but I think one of
or there's a couple of things I'd suggest really is making sure that what you're doing is not only for the purpose of gaining experience, but also something that you genuinely really enjoy and feel interested in, because that will make such a difference to you day to day. And as I say, recognising those limits, I think we in this career path have a lot of perfectionism, and that can drive us to push a lot of the time and and in some ways that's a really brilliant trait but also what is very helpful is being able to recognize when you need to take a step back and when you need to look after yourself um and i think just one of the the biggest pieces of advice i would give particularly for those either getting onto the doctorate now pushing to get there already studying is just to look after yourself outside of work and outside of studying do the
things that feel nourishing to you say no when you need to prioritize you and your time and rest time and know that rest is just as productive as doing. Beautiful, so lovely and so important. Amy, thank you so much for speaking with us. It's been incredible. It's not a topic that we've covered trauma stabilisation, but it's so important. And actually, what we found is that sometimes people choose not to go on to process their traumas, because they are feeling that they can manage everything so much better. So things do stay in their box more and we can think about it as phases of internet intervention so maybe we do the stabilization phase and maybe in a couple of years they might feel ready and have the necessary bolt-on skills to be able to tolerate that
processing stage better absolutely and that's why it's so important to think about right order right thing right time absolutely thank you so much for your time it's been a beautiful episode thanks amy thank you for having me marion you're so welcome thank you so much to our guest amy i think she's just doing an incredible job and the service sound like a really brilliant service to be part of, very thoughtful, compassionate, empathic, and hopefully the clients are finding it to be a really, really valuable service. What has this evoked for you? Has this made you think about whether you could deliver something similar in future? Has it made you think about whether you'd like to learn some trauma stabilization skills to either help yourself or to help the clients you're working with? Do check out the
Feel Better Academy, which is available on the short course area of my website, which is www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash short hyphen courses where you can get the Feel Better Academy for £49.99 which will help you as an aspiring psychologist or clinician to be able to learn those skills, those strategies to be able to help yourself and the clients you work with. I would love any feedback you've got about this episode. Please do come along and follow me on socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere, but also come and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist community, and let me know what you think there too. Take a moment to rate and review the podcast. It would be so appreciated. It's the kindest free thing you can do for me. And please also, if you're watching
on YouTube, please do subscribe to the channel. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Please do stay kind to yourselves. And I will be back along with the next episode, 10am on YouTube on Saturdays and 6am on Mondays for the MP3. Take care. See you very soon. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical
Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.